[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue ses
sens public 90 minutes de débat de
reportages et d' analyse comme tous les
jours sur public sénat avec nos experts
on donne du sens à l'actualité 18h 22h
du lundi au jeudi et voici le sommaire
de ce 14 septembre comment mieux
encadrer la chasse comment mieux
partager la nature entre chasseurs et
promeneurs c'est l'objectif du rapport
sénatorial remis aujourd'hui
interdiction de l'alcool et des
stupéfiants formation renforcée
certificat médical annuel mais pas de
jour sans chasse c'était pourtant l'une
des principales revendications des 122
mille signataires de la pétition à
l'origine de ce rapport ça nous promet
un débat passionnant dans une minute
c'est l'une des polémiques de l'été un
jeu organisé au centre pénitentiaire de
fresnes avec notamment une course de
kart une polémique hypocrite alors que
le vrai scandale c'est l'état lamentable
de nos prisons voilà ce que dit la
contrôleuse et lieux de privation de
liberté qui est participera à notre
second débat tout à l'heure à quoi sert
la prison comme on lutter contre la
surpopulation carcérale le gouvernement
construite il suffisamment de nouvelles
maisons d'arrêt beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
donc ce rapport du sénat sur la chasse
il est résumé par jonathan des prières
mieux encadrer la chasse pour limiter
les accidents voilà l'objectif du
rapport du sénat publié aujourd'hui à
l'issue de plusieurs mois d'auditions et
de déplacements de terrain en résulte 30
propositions dont certaines risquent de
faire couler beaucoup d'encre y compris
du côté des pro chasse les sénateurs
plaide par exemple pour renforcer
l'examen du permis de chasser ils
réclament aussi une formation théorique
et pratique pour posséder une carabine
les parlementaires veulent aussi rendre
obligatoire l'obtention d'un certificat
médical chaque année pour chasser les
sénateurs préconisent aussi d'interdire
l'usagé de stupéfiants et de l'alcool
lors des parties de chasse en s'alignant
sur le code de la route avoir quelqu'un
qui a un fusil dans les mains et qui en
état d'ébriété ça pose quand même
question est aujourd'hui la
réglementation fait que bah rien ne
l'interdît quelqu'un qui est sur ses
terres
avec un petit verre dans le nez qui
porte son arme personne ne peut rien
faire personne ne peut rien lui dire je
crois que il ya une correction à faire
mais certains points du rapport ont
provoqué la colère des écologistes
notamment l'absence de jours sans chasse
au niveau national et c'est surtout la
20e proposition consacrant la création
d'un délit d' entrave à l'achat ce qui a
fait bondir certains sénateurs comme
daniel salmon cette proposition numéro
20 fait un petit peu tâche pour moi dans
ce rapport parce que elle rompt un peu
le postulat de départ qui disait ce
n'est pas un rapport pour ou contre la
chasse c'est un rapport sur la sécurité
et là on arrive sur j'entends bien je
vois bien comment ça s'est passé c'est
une c'est une préconisation d' équilibre
pour faire passer pas mal de choses qui
sont fortes pour les faire passer auprès
des chasseurs donc on a mis cette
préconisation enfin patrick chaize la
mise je pense que elle n'a rien à faire
là et que il faut l'enlever c'est une
atteinte aux libertés quelque part
d'autres mesures figurent dans le
rapport notamment sur le suivi des armes
en circulation ou sur la compétence des
policiers municipaux en matière de
chasse ces travaux pourraient donner
lieu à une proposition de loi
prochainement
voilà notre débat sur la chasse alors
j'vais transparent avec vous il ya
certaines aux invités qui sont entre la
gare montparnasse et et le sénat qui
vont arriver d'autres qu'on est en train
d'essayer de joindre par skype en
visioconférence mais heureusement hélène
barbry et la bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
porte parole des associations de défense
des victimes de la chasse et d'animaux
ça regroupe plusieurs collectifs
notamment le collectif un jour un
chasseur ruraux en colère enfin je vais
pas citer toutes les associations mais à
l'origine de cette pétition qui a reçu
122 mille signatures et qui a donc
provoqué notamment ce rapport du sénat
avec nous également en visioconférence
en duplex tancrède de la morinerie
bonsoir bienvenue merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes directeur des
rédactions de riz world media et donc du
magazine le chasseur français matthieu
croissandeau est à mes côtés évidemment
éditorialiste politique bonsoir mathieu
peut-être une réaction un peu générale
hélène barbry on vient de résumer dans
notre sujet les propositions va dire les
plus importantes de ce rapport bon on en
a parlé un petit peu avant vous êtes
déçu c'est clair oui on est déçu alors
juste pour préciser je parle au nom du
collectif un jour un chasseur a gardé
opposants à la chasse animal cross ça se
passe havas la fondation brigitte bardot
la lfb à la lp o one voice track ruraux
en colère et stéphane lamart ça montre
quand même qu'on est nombreux à être
sensibles à ce dossier quand on a lu le
rapport on a été extrêmement déçu il ne
faut pas oublier que la pétition elle
part d'une victime morgan pour rappeler
les faits qui avaient 25 ans qui
taillait du bois dans son jardin avec un
casque orange fluo sur les oreilles et
qui a été abattu d'une balle en plein
thorax par un chasseur qui l'a pris pour
un sanglier donc cette pétition elles
viennent de la douleur de proches et au
final on aboutit à un rapport qui
dépénalise qui proposent de dépénaliser
des infractions qui propose d'aider
discutent des déductions fiscales pour
les chasseurs et on n'est pas du tout
dans ce qu'on avait ce qu'on avait
demandé
je me tourne vers vous tancrède de la
morinerie j'imagine que vous avez pris
connaissance des de ses 30 propositions
on a le sentiment
que quand même le lobby des chasseurs a
pesé beaucoup plus que celui des non
chasseurs avant la rédaction de ce
rapport et vous
en fait j'ai pas tout à fait la même
vision que moi j'ai surtout l'impression
que ni les chasseurs ni les personnes
qui ont signé
des associations présentes madame sont
satisfaits du rapport d'une certaine
façon je dirais que du coup le politique
a peut-être bien fait son travail parce
que si il les uns ni les autres sont
totalement satisfait ça veut dire qu'ils
ont fait peut-être preuve d'indépendance
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont quand même
écouté beaucoup de monde
voilà c'est un rapport c'est à dire
qu'ils font des préconisations alors ça
peut peut-être pas satisfaire tout le
monde en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet je trouve qu'il s'en empare en
ayant un certain nombre de propositions
qui peuvent peut-être plaire ou nouveaux
chasseurs 12 ans qui s'opposaient à la
chasse mais en tout cas ça ça permet au
moins d'avoir une base pour pouvoir
regarder ces questions il ya eu
effectivement plus de 170 audition ici
au sénat donc ça a été un travail de
fond qui a été réalisée je reste avec
vous tanqueray de la morinerie qu'est ce
qui pour vous peut déplaire aux
chasseurs dans ce rapport
je pense que ça peut avoir un certain
nombre de contraintes et de mise en
place de choses qui peuvent
effectivement
déplaire ou en tout cas voilà les
chasseurs pour trouvé ça assez
contraignant en revanche le rapport
montre qu'il ya une très forte baisse
depuis 20 ans des accidents de chasse et
ça vraiment moi qui m'ont permis de
chasse tous horizons et du chasseur je
m'en réjouis parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya eu des victimes c'est un drame
et les les chasseurs sont les premiers
choqué il faut le dire c'est ça aussi
donc moi je trouve ça bien que nier
c'est très forte baisse des accidents de
chasse et ça va continuer parce qu'il
faut aller un matin à une chasse en
battue entre sangliers pour voir comment
sont répétés à chaque fois les consignes
comme comment tous les chefs de l'hymne
est responsable de chasse sont impliqués
donc c'est rentré depuis longtemps dans
les moeurs et maintenant je pense que
les chasseurs sont extrêmement prudents
donc ça je à nouveau on va encore
insisté sur ces choses là et tant mieux
quoi alors je vous donne la parole sur
sur ces chiffres et sur la baisse des
accidents matthew intervenir moi je suis
pas du tout un spécialiste de la chasse
mais j'ai lu ce rapport donc comme comme
un béotien qui découvrent et je trouve
que ça dresse un constat des pratiques
actuelles en creux qui me paraît assez
désarçonnant si j'ose dire je prends
quatre propositions la numéro 4
renforcer l'examen du permis de chasser
en rendant obligatoire la maîtrise des
armes semi automatiques on sait qu'il y
en a quand même quelques unes et une
épreuve de performance au tir donc déjà
on peut chasser sans son sens forcément
être performant au tir jours c'est quand
même assez dangereux rendre le
certificat médical obligatoire comme
pour tous les autres sports d'armes
c'est l'accalmie l1 chaque adhérent on
en a un qu'on pouvait pas la nouvelle
écurie mais à noël c'est sinon voilà on
peut être n'importe quel état de santé
on peut avoir la maladie de parkinson et
continue à chasser comme ça pendant
pendant des années interdire l'alcool et
l' usage de stupéfiants lors de la
chasse mais où on en est je verrai ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on peut se
rendre l'entendait dans le reportage
tout à l'heure chasser alors qu'on alors
qu'on est bourré jeu développé une
culture du tir bas on espère que on a
développé une culture du tir et je vous
donne la dernière sur la sécurité qui
m'a profondément choqué je me demande où
ces gens vivent d'alors graduée la
suspension ou le retrait du permis de
chasser en fonction de la gravité de
l'infraction en clair en cas d'homicide
partir direct le retrait du permis
pourrait être systématique et
l'interdiction de repasser porter à 10
ans autrement dit quand vous avez un
chasseur qui tue quelqu'un partir direct
le ce la suspension du permis n'est pas
automatique aujourd'hui les là les
sénateurs recommandent qu'elle pourrait
être systématique et qu'on pourrait lui
interdire de repasser le permis pendant
dix ans enfin dans quel monde on vit une
tanqueray de la morinerie est ce que
vous voyez là sûrement d'écrans de
contrôle un peu un peu réagir
c'est moi j'ai eu un peu le même
sentiment en lisant le rapport cet après
midi alors peut-être que nous on est des
des urbains
hors sol jeudi trois anti chasse est
cadrée mais on se dit comment ça n'a pas
été fait avant
en fait c c il ya un problème de
méconnaissance sur la chasse et l'examen
du permis de chasse il faut savoir que
le permis de chasse vous avez deux
examens vous avez un examen théorique un
examen pratique examen pratique vous
avez pendant une journée vous êtes
devant des inspecteurs de l'office
français de la diversité vous leur
montrez comment vous maniez larmes
si à un moment vous avez un geste qui
peut porter à confusion sur la façon
dont vous maniéré sais pas vous êtes
éliminés donc ça veut dire que comme
monsieur votre journal d'ailleurs très
sympathique un jeu règles de l'emmener à
la chasse pour lui faire découvrir à
quoi ça correspond vraiment en fait on
est habitué à manier des armes depuis
notre plus tendre enfance depuis l'âge
de 16 ans on va dans des stands de tir
on est accompagné par nous ou nos pères
nos grands pères voilà on multiplie on
multiplie le maniement d'armé lors du
permis de chasse effectivement on
contrôle si on sait bien se servir d'une
arme entre autres fusils de casser des
armées l'armée tout ça est par ailleurs
je voudrais quand même dire un truc
c'est que l'amalgamme sur l'alcool
éventuellement les spéciales et des
stupéfiants la chasse c'est désolant
bien évidemment cette annonce est écrit
noir sur blanc dans le rapport donc si
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans le
rapport c'est bien qu'il ya un souci
non mais c'est qu'il ya pas du tout
souci je veux dire regardez quand quand
il ya des accidents en état d'ébriété
par exemple comme quelqu'un conduit on
demande pas tous les gens qui montent
dans leur voiture de souffler dans le
ballon
vous voyez ce que je veux dire je vais
peut-être qu'une fois ou deux il ya eu
des gens qui ont été en état d'ébriété
et et le cas malheureusement de morgane
que citer madame la personne n'était pas
en aide à état d'ébriété vous voyez ce
que je veux dire donc arrêtons ces
amalgames je vous en supplie quoi c'est
atroce quoi alors la parole de revenir
vers vous si vous êtes en voiture et que
vous faites arrêter par la gendarmerie
qui vous fait souffler
si vous êtes alcoolisées on vous retire
le permis de même vous allez en force
à laisser parler les barbry vous avez eu
la parole dont je leur donnerai vous ne
le retire pas le permis si vous chassez
sous l'emprise de l'alcool c'est
parfaitement légal et par rapport aux
homicides dont vous parliez il faut
savoir qu'un homicide involontaire
commis en voiture et sanctionner
beaucoup plus sévèrement que l'homicide
involontaire commis à la chasse et les
suspensions de permis elles sont de 5 10
ans et ses 10 ans et elles sont très
très faiblement
prononcée par les juges je voulais juste
vous dire un petit témoignage pour vous
montrer l'ampleur de la problématique de
ces suspensions et de 2,7 des péni
dépénalisation qu'il y a
c'était en 2012 nicolas 12 ans fait du
quad comme chaque dimanche avec son père
en seine maritime il tombe sur un groupe
de chasseurs et s'arrête le chasseur
leur demande vous n'avez pas vu les
pancartes il répond qu'il n'en avait pas
à l'entrée du chemin la suite c'est le
père du défunt de l'enfant qui raconte
au moment où j'allais mettre en route le
quad j'ai entendu le coup de feu j'ai
senti nicolas s'écrouler sur mon dos le
chasseur disais merde de merde j'ai fait
le con j'ai vu le petit la tête pleine
de sens les chasseurs ont essayé de
faire les premiers soins c'était trop
tard fana citation l' expertise
balistique dira que le fusil était très
vieux que son cran de sécurité ne
fonctionnait pas que le chasseur n'avait
pas cassé son fusil 5il la vie respecté
aucune règle de sécurité et qu'est-ce
qu'il a eue ce monsieur il a une
suspension de cinq ans du permis de
chasse pour avoir tué un enfant de 12
ans en quad qu'il avait face à lui on
est vraiment dans une dans une problème
il a pas eu de prison ferme rien on est
vraiment dans une problème dans un
problème de sanctions hélas ce rapport
il propose en proposition numéro 10 de
développer des stages alternatif aux
poursuites pénales en cas de
comportements dangereux on est dans une
aile un allègement
de dpn donc vous dites que depuis 2012
en fait parce que ça lave de 2012 que
vous nous racontez ça n'a pas vraiment
changé on pourrait en citer là je
voulais lire ce témoignage parce qu'il
est poignant mais on pourrait en citer
et quand j'entends que les accidents
diminue là aussi je suis désolé je suis
obligé de rebondir sur les chiffres je
pense qu'il manque d'un statitiques d'un
statisticien au sénat
les chiffres sont complètement fausses
et ils sont biaisés les calculs s'en
faut on ose comparer les accidents de
chasse à des accidents de trampoline ou
de marche nordique mais un trampoline ou
des chaussures de marche non pas pour
finalité la mort de quelqu'un en fait
vous donne animal
on compare le nombre d'accidents de
chasse au nombre d'accidents de voiture
qui percute des animaux mais il ya 38
millions de véhicules qui circulent de
bidules de voiture il ya un million de
chasseurs donc on ne peut pas comparer
ces chiffres là est vraiment c'est
incroyable de voir qu'ils ont travaillé
autant de mois sur un rapport et qui
rien n'est concret rien et fiable alors
vous avez l'un et l'autre
citer une autre une autre affaire qui
avait évidemment défrayé la chronique et
je vais vous proposer tout de suite de
voir un extrait extrait d'un
documentaire d'un reportage format long
réalisé par samia de sheer journalistes
de la rédaction de de public sénat c'est
justement l'histoire de morgane avec ça
sa compagne qui quitte à l'origine d'une
des pétitions elle témoigne dans ce
documentaire regardé c'était le 2
décembre 2020 vers 16h50 17h donc en
plein hiver cinq journées
c'était encore en confinement et morgane
est allé couper du bois dans ce bosquet
ici qui se trouve à une centaine de
mètres de sa maison
il avait un casque orange une
tronçonneuse est en fait assez vous
allez autour de 16h 50 17 heures il ya
un chasseur qui l'a pris pour un
sanglier et qu'il a qui attire et qui
l'a touché au thorax
il a été il ya eu une tentative de
réanimation
et mais au final il est décédé quelques
minutes après
lendemain il ya le procureur du lot qui
a dit que toutes les règles de sécurité
avaient été respectées
du coup on s'est dit mais comment
comment il peut y avoir
un assassinat du d'un homme alors que
des règles de sécurité ont été
respectées ça veut dire que les règles
ne sont pas du tout suffisante donc ça
c'est la sphère le drame qui déclenche
d'une certaine façon là la pétition je
propose à quand un calme et de de nous
rejoindre tout de suite quand un parce
que il ya donc ce rapport et c'est un
long processus qui a précédé ce rapport
avec cette forme de démocratie
participative qui a démarré d'ailleurs
il ya plusieurs années on peut le dire
tout à fait thomas c'est au moment où la
france en fait lancé sa première
convention citoyenne celle rappelez-vous
sur le climat à l'automne 2010 9 que le
sénat a mis en place cette initiative
on sait que la chambre eu autant est
plutôt frileuses en matière de
démocratie participative
mais c'est un pas en fait dans cette
direction
annoncé par gérard larcher est dans une
conférence de presse en septembre 2019
alors l'idée thomas c'est tout simple
n'importe quel citoyen peut publier son
idée de pétition sur le site du sénat ça
n'a point fr il faut ensuite réunir cent
mille signatures dans un délai maximal
de six mois si ce seuil est atteint et
cela a été le cas quatre fois depuis que
et bien cette initiative a été prise la
conférence des présidents du sénat est
saisie il s'agit un de l'organe du sénat
qui organise le travail parlementaire et
alors cette instance pu organiser
mission flash une commission denquête ou
encore un débat dans l'hémicycle donc
vous nous disiez 4 pétition ont atteint
ce seuil des cent mille signatures
lesquels en fait c'est vrai que cette
initiative elle a pris du temps à être
connu du grand public mais le rythme
auquel les pétitions sont signés et
maintenant en constante accélération est
alors parmi les quatre pétition sur le
site du sénat qui ont très bien marché
il y en a trois sur quatre qui sont
consacrés au thème de la chasse c'est
dire comme ce sujet et clivant et on
l'entend dans vos débats en plateau et
commence à mobiliser l'opinion et donc
on pense donc à cette première pétition
autour de ce qui s'est passé avec
morgane et que vous évoquez est lancée
par ces deux jeunes femmes qui avaient
perdu donc cet ami dans un accident de
chasse c'est donc cette initiative un
qui a provoqué la mission de contrôle
qui a travaillé le février à juillet
dernier cas rendu son rapport
aujourd'hui en contre-feu le président
de la fédération nationale de la chasse
willy schraen il a également lancé sa
propre pétition qui a aussi atteint les
100 mille signatures alors lui son idée
c'est de priver de subventions des ong
qui commettent des délits dans sa ligne
de mire il vise des associations qui
commettent des actions d' entrave de
violence d'intrusion ou de dégradations
au nom de la cause animale et donc ça
c'est qu'effectivement quelque chose qui
a également réuni cent mille signatures
et puis là au mois de septembre nouvelle
pétition qui atteint ce seuil voilà là
l'interdiction dieu pour l'interdiction
du déterrage de blaireaux une technique
de chasse jugées cruelles par des
écologistes et plusieurs associations
pour voilà pour la cause est la cause
animale et de leur côté les chasseurs
explique que cette population d'animaux
sains de blaireaux elle doit être
régulée dans certains départements elle
peut détruire la vigne ou endommagé les
voies ferrées donc on verra quelle suite
le sénat donne voilà cette dernière
pétition sur le blaireau un que vous
voyez à l'image on voit donc aussi que
l'initiative lancée en 2019 par le sénat
c'est au coeur d'une bataille de cliquer
acharnée entre pro et anti-chasse comme
à merci beaucoup il ya beaucoup
d'éléments à sur lesquels rebondir avec
à nos invités dans ce débat tancrède
delà de la morinerie je rappelle que des
directeurs de rédaction de du groupe
reward médias et donc du chasseur
français c'est cette notion de
régulation expliquez nous le rôle des
chasseurs pourquoi c'est important et et
pourquoi aussi c'est souvent ce qui est
mis en avant par les fédérations les
associations de chasseurs
en fait c'est assez simple aujourd'hui
grâce aux efforts qui ont été faits
parce qu'on a mis en place qui est le
plan de chasse dire que chaque année il
ya un certain nombre d'animaux qui sont
attribués en fonction de la densité des
massifs forestiers par exemple pour les
chevreuils le cerf ou de sanglier et un
certain nombre d'animaux qui doivent
être élevés et entre autres il ya une
énorme problématique aujourd'hui sur le
sanglier en france puisqu'il ya près
d'un million 200 billets qui sont
prélevés par an et malgré les efforts
des chasseurs a aujourd'hui les
chasseurs chasse quasiment deux années
on va dire il commence à chasser le
sanglier en battue à partir al'approche
à partir de juin et en battue à partir
d'août jusqu'en février parfois avec des
prolongements jusqu'en mars et il reste
quand même dans plein de territoires en
france dès surpopulation de sangliers
qui viennent manger dans les poubelles
comme vous le voyez leur désinformation
des actualités ou qui détériorent les
living et puis surtout qui détériorent
très fortement les cultures donc on a un
problème c'est qu'on n'arrive plus à
venir à bout de ces les populations
gigantesque maintenant de sanglier et en
plus le gros problème c'est que ce sont
seuls des chasseurs qui supporte les ce
qu'on appelle les dégâts de grand gibier
c'est à dire que c'est ni fédération des
chasseurs et ceux qui payent leur permis
qui paye entièrement les dégâts de qui
sont causés aux agriculteurs et aux
cultures chaque année il ya certaines
fédérations de chasseurs qui n'arrivent
plus à payer ce parce que ces dégâts
parce que c'est en millions d'euros donc
ça devient une vraie problématique et je
pense que c'est un problème sociétal ça
veut dire comment on fait aujourd'hui
pour faire en sorte qu'elles moins de
5000 j'accueille fabrique dans les
journaliste spécialiste des questions
d'environnement c'est moi pour morte et
vous n'y êtes pour rien c'est ce sont
les traces harkis qui ont joué leur
mauvais rôle aujourd'hui ça arrive ce
n'est pas bien grave je rappelle que
vous êtes journal spécialisé questions
d'environnement et auteur de la chasse
le vrai du faux aux éditions delachaux
et et et nièces les vous avez du coup
j'aime pas du tout dire du coup donc je
m'en veux de l'avoir de la voir glisser
dans une phrase vous avez eu encore plus
de temps pour lire le leur âge d'or et
ses 30 propositions
finalement est-ce que vous êtes surpris
par ce rapport à ce que le sénat qui est
quand même une instance
des territoires de la ruralité pouvait
aller dans un autre sens d'après non
parce que c'est le sénat c'est sur un
ton long et c'est la ruralité face à un
parlement qui est plutôt sur un temps
court et l'urbanité donc le sénat le
sénat défend l'image qu'il se fait de la
ruralité et l'image de la ruralité a été
approprié par la chasse parce que on est
impie de rapports de force et parce que
les chasseurs c'est une seule tête willy
schraen qui défend qui prétend défendre
la biodiversité les animaux réguler les
sangliers et représenter c'est vrai
c'est vrai que les chasseurs sur les
populations de sangliers il ya un rôle
de régulateur qu'on peut pas nier oui
marolles de ryanair qui fonctionne pas
ça ne fonctionne plus les chasseurs sont
en partie jeudi en participant totalité
responsable de la situation des
sangliers parce qu'il fut un temps où
les agréent nez il fut un temps on les a
nourris par ce qu'il fallait il fallait
qu'on puisse chasser des sangles et
parce qu'il n'y avait plus de petits de
deux petites proies le comment vous dire
le la transformation du modèle agricole
dans les années 60 70 80 le fait que la
biodiversité a chuté et en gros
caricaturalement on chasse plus de
perdrix donc on s'est mis à chasser en
baie de somme par exemple des gibiers
d'eau et puis on s'est mis à chasser
encore plus qu'avant du sanglier
puisqu'il n'en avaient pas assez il fut
un temps dans les années 70 où on les
nourrissait est arrivé là dessus le
changement climatique et favoriser les
portes etc pour qu'aujourd'hui où il ya
plus que les chasseurs il n'y a pas que
ya aussi des chasseurs dit assez remonté
par exemple ou nf les louvetiers mais
ils s'en sortent plus non quand les
chasseurs 10 on réguler cette
biodiversité
déséquilibré c'est faux et archi faux il
ne régule plus rien la situation lors a
complètement échappé à échapper à tout
le monde oui il nous manque dans ce
débat un sénateur ou une sénatrice pour
défendre leurs rapports sont des choses
qui arrivent j'aime panique le rapport
était pardon mais je voudrais du coup
redonné la parole à tancrède delà de la
morinerie sur ce rôle de régulateur
parce que vous manifestants avec
frédéric dans l'est vous avez deux
visions qui sont pas là même qui sont
pas les mêmes expliquez-nous
alors en fait
votre journaliste qui vient d'arriver là
il a en partie raison mais c'est c'est
toujours compliqué d'expliquer des
choses comme ça par exemple moi ce que
je trouve génial c'est grâce au plan de
chasse on voit plein de nous ferons
quand le chevreuil clown cercle un
design chamois parc on a on a plein de
grands gibiers partout il faut quand
même le dire c'est parce que c'est les
chasseurs qui s'en sont beaucoup plus qu
paie aujourd'hui si encore des petits
petra des grands des draps en français
parce que les chasseurs ils vont couper
les myrtilles ils vont ils vont
s'occuper justement des milieux donc
arrêtons tout le temps de taper sur les
chasseurs moi je suis un écologiste mais
vraiment je fais plein de choses chez
moi pour l'aménagement des territoires
et tout ça donc je vois très bien tout
ce que je fais ça profite à l'ensemble
de la faune et j'en suis le premier
premier à dire que c'est super gt
ornithologues avant d'être chasseur vous
voyez je peux pas je suis capable de
partir avec tous les gens qui sont sur
votre plateau et je prendrai grand
plaisir à les emmener faire de leurs
mythologies pourquoi pas maison de la
chasse il dire qu'aujourd'hui on régule
plus rien et qu'on s'en occupe a donc ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que on a
un problème d'abondance je veux dire sur
sur le sanglier on n'a pas le même sur
un peu le même sur le sert de temps en
temps mais globalement l'intervention et
la bonne gestion des chasseurs fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de grands
gibiers en france si les gens quand ils
se baladent le week-end ils le disent
tous on voit plus de grand gibier c'est
en partie parce que les chasseurs s'en
sont occupés et l'arrêt réfaction pardon
la raréfaction du petit gibier entre du
perdreau d'autre part et c'est un prime
de deux cultures mais de culture
agricole bah c'est pas les chasseurs il
ya il y a deux petits points que
j'aimerais relever par rapport à vos
propos
la première chose c'est que
effectivement les chasseurs se plaignent
presque de ce devoir de service public
pour faire respecter l'ordre public de
devoir tuer des sangliers qu'il
préférerait souvent faire de la chasse
au petit gibier mais la question se pose
pourquoi y at il encore un prince
aujourd'hui 350 élevage de sangliers
pourquoi il y a encore 14 millions de
faisans 5 millions de paires dit ricky
sont élevées pour être chassés si
vraiment les chasseurs vous en avez
marre de chasser les sangliers arrêté
d'en élever pour les chasser la deuxième
chose que je voulais soulevé c'est pour
rapporter les propos de votre président
willy schraen qui a dit l'année passée
la radio rmc je cite qui est s'est
adressé à la journaliste toi tu penses
qu'on est là pour réguler mais t'as pas
compris t'as pas compris que pour nous
c'est une passion n'a pas compris qu'on
parle du plaisir d'un acte de chasse et
a pas compris ça tu crois que nous on va
devenir effectivement les petites mains
de la régulation moi mon métier c'est
pas chasseur j'en ai rien à de
réguler à partir du moment où votre
porte parole à ces propos en public on
se pose question quant à la réalité de
la régulation et en suisse au canton de
genève la chasse est interdite il régule
autrement il n'y a pas d'accident mais
ça se passe très bien bon jeu j'ai
entendu ce comité mais je reviens vers
vous temps crée de la monnaie on peut on
peut réguler et ça peut être aussi une
passion c'est pas antinomiques en fait
ces deux choses différentes c'est à dire
que il ya la passion de la chasse à dire
l'acte de se balader dans la nature avec
un rapport différent effectivement que
d'autres personnes quand on est dans la
nature et la régulation effectivement de
ce ce que voulait dire et de façon à
peut-être provocateur le président de la
fnc c'est que se retrouver tous les
dimanches nous tous les toutes les
semaines roues on a comme consigne de
prélever des sangliers sait pas
forcément ce qu'on a envie quoi vous
voyez comme moi je me retrouve temps en
temps dans des sociétés de chasse dans
le sud-ouest où on arrivait le matin et
10 voilà il ya encore des sangliers dans
les domaines haïssent ils envoient les
chiens tout ça est le truc c'est tout ce
qui sort on essaie d'en tirer le maximum
dont parfois délais suite et
puisqu'aujourd'hui les consignes c'est
ça c'est que parfois sur certains
territoires vous-même prélever délais
c'est-à-dire des femelles qui peuvent
être gestantes ou qui ont des ti
croyez-moi nous ça nous fait pas marrer
du tout pendant des années on les a
épargnés justement pour permettre à ces
populations de se développer aujourd'hui
on en est essayé de de prélever de
réguler le maximum le maximum de 100
billets est effectivement
disons que c'est un contexte qui est
totalement aux de se dire qu'on a
l'impression de mettre une casquette est
effectivement avoir une mission de
service public alors que c'est pas celle
que pour laquelle normalement on prend
notre permis de chasse vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
je vais alimenter le débat allez-y
terminée maintenant c'est vrai c'est un
c'est un vrai débat ça veut dire que
vous parliez madame du canton de genève
et dieu sait si un sujet qu'on a et dans
nos magazines quand vous dit que ça se
passe bien non ça se passe pas très bien
fonctionné
papa s'est dit on va pas passer dix
minutes sur le canton de genève en
revanche la vraie question et je vais
redonner ralala par la fnac dans et
juste après c'est la question est
évidemment de ce partage la de la nature
partage des espaces naturels et c'est
pas forcément simple pour les élus je
vous propose un autre extrait du
reportage de samia de sheer
donc long reportage qu'on a qu'on a
diffusé il ya quelques mois elle est
cette fois ci à l'ail et on est dans une
commune d'ille et vilaine et là aussi ça
commence par un drame un automobiliste a
été tué par une balle perdue puis
ensuite ya la question on y revient de
la prolifération des sangliers de la
réaction de la mère face à cet accident
mortel regardez bien donc ça compense
pas les sangliers sont de plus en plus
nombreux ra d'âge les terres des
agriculteurs
tout ça c'est des dégâts non mais on
voit bien que tout est arraché quoi il
n'y avait pas que un sanglier encore
faire pousser des gars là c'est des
bandes de sangliers qui viennent toutes
les demies régulièrement ya un peu plus
de la moitié de la parfaite qui étaient
touchés chaque année les sangliers abîme
8 hectares des terres de ce couple une
perte sèche de 5000 euros c'est
difficile psychologiquement très
difficile vous allez pouvoir le smur si
vous n'avez pas peur mais normalement
n'y a pas de souci après l'accident
dramatique qui écoutait levy un homme
sur sa commune la mère de leye a pris
une décision radicale
on a pris un arrêté sur la commune
interdisant toute action de chasse dans
les 150 mètres autour des habitations
obligeant
les chiens de chasse à être tenus en
laisse dans les 150 mètres autour des
habitations et interdisant le tir à la
carabine sur toute la connu la réaction
n'a pas manqué très vite les chasseurs
ont rangé leurs armes et globalement la
chasse c'est complètement arrêté le 11
novembre
parce que je sors estimé qu'avec ces
restrictions il ne pouvait plus chasser
d'accord ils vous ont fait une petite
petite mesure de rétorsion en disant
vous allez beaucoup trop loin donc nous
on chasse plus du tout et vous allez
voir ce que ça va donner eu que les
communes des environs ont été chassés
l'ail et n'était plus à chasser
l'animal il n'est pas fou hein donc en
fait il me revenait sur la commune se
réfugier dans les bois de l'ail est mené
c'est par une surpopulation de sangliers
sur sa commune la mère a dû faire marche
arrière élevés sont arrêtés
c'est intéressant parce que on est là
sur la puissance locale or c'est aussi
un vrai maillage local c'est une vie
sociale la chasse faut jamais l'oublier
c'est une tradition il ya tout ça mais
il ya aussi cette puissance divine des
élus locaux c'est pas simple quand on
est élu local de s'attaquer je mets des
guillemets aux chasseurs bah oui parce
que dans un village quand il ya même
plus de pauses plus de boucherie plus
rien plus d'associations sportives reste
plus que les chasseurs qui font vivre le
tissu social après les chasseurs dans
toutes les fées des jazz les faits déjà
ce genre d'enquêté pour ce bouquin un
président de fédé de chasse m'avait dit
ce pas compliqué nous on a le pouvoir
d'aller voir tous les élus de notre
territoire quels qu'ils soient en moins
de 24 heures donc ils ont un pouvoir
d'influencé
relativement important qui fait peur qui
fait peur aux élus locaux et qui peut
les dissuader de d'engager une action
contre le monde de la chasse qui encore
une fois se présente comme le seul
garant le seul héros de la ruralité
alors faut arrêter d'un côté de taper
sur les chasseurs en permanence ce qu'on
leur prochainement cette pâte hypocrite
comme nous c'est à dire que vont tuer
pour manger dans un monde une société
qui refuse tout même les insultes qui
refusent le sentent et ils le font très
bien moi j'ai rien à dire là-dessus mais
en même temps les chasseurs faut quand
même qu'ils comprennent que le monde a
changé que même la ruralité a changé qui
a des chasseurs traditionnels que sont
les agriculteurs les agriculteurs
partent en retraite dont il ya moins de
ces chasseurs traditionnels il ya plus
de néo ruraux il ya plus deux jeunes car
n'ont rien à faire de la chasse avec du
coup les problèmes qu'il y aura demain
sur les sangliers c'est certain mais en
tout cas accordé un jour de semaine sans
chasse oui ce serait un pas en terme de
communication ce serait oui ce serait
bien même si d'autres pays européens
contrairement à ce qu'on dit ne font pas
au moins qu'il fasse ça et ça je pense
que ça faciliterait la vie de tout le
monde et ça faciliterait la vie des
mères parce que ça diminuerait les
tensions alors ça ne fait pas partie des
propositions de ce rapport du sénat la
proposition numéro 28 ne pas retenir
deux jours sans chasse au niveau
national et materis les mettre en place
le cadre de dialogue qui permettra d
adaptation locale concertée entre les
acteurs du territoire puisqu'on parle de
la puissance mathieu dudule du lobby des
chasseurs vous avez voulu vous pencher
sur cette relation particulière avec le
président de la république oui parce que
c'est beau comme une histoire d'amour le
6 avril dernier emmanuel macron alors en
pleine campagne présidentielle prenez sa
plus belle plume pour écrire une lettre
à willy schraen dont on a parlé ici le
tout puissant président de la toute
puissante fédération nationale des
chasseurs
durant les cinq années nous avons eu un
dialogue régulier franc et constructif
minaudait le candidat faux modeste dans
un genre de remerciement à peine voilée
parce que quelques semaines plus tôt le
même willy schraen lui avait appelé à
voter pour emmanuel macron et dès le
premier tour s'il vous plaît un
président qui mettra toute son énergie
pour répondre à nos demandes j'ai sa
parole il ne m'a jamais déçu par il
manquerait plus que ça parce que depuis
l'élection de l'un des macros en 2017
les chasseurs n'ont jamais été aussi
bien traiter c'est une salve de cadeaux
qui s'est abattue sur les amoureux de la
gâchette de la part d'un président qui
se piquent par ailleurs d'être un
chantre de la biodiversité de dérogation
décret le président a mis dans le mille
à chaque fois resté dernière l'exécutif
n'a pas hésité à lancer par exemple de
grande consultation publique sur le site
de matignon pour contourner des
décisions du conseil d'état tenté de
contourner des décisions du conseil
d'état qui visait à restreint des
méthodes de chasse traditionnelle qui
serait ce que l'on conseil d'état
contraire au droit européen
l'exécutif a aussi raccourci les délais
entre la promulgation du calendrier
officiel de la chasse et l'ouverture
effective de la chasse histoire
dénoncent les associations de les
prendre de vitesse pour pas qu'elle ait
le temps de déposer des recours mais
c'est rien même à côté du tableau de
chasse financiers pourquoi la fédération
nationale des chasseurs n'a jamais été
aussi riche oui grâce à une série de
décisions qui aboutit à une augmentation
alors d aides de l'état calculé par ruse
en colère je crois une association ou
représentés de 23000 % en cinq ans pour
faire simple fait d'avoir eu la division
par deux du prix du permis de chasse de
400 à 200 euros c'est en fait c'est un
coup de pouce on pourrait dire que ça
rapporte moins mais non en fait ça
rapporte plus parce qu'avant les
chasseurs prenez plutôt des permis dans
les faits auprès des fédérations
départementales et là ça a rapporté à la
fédération nationale qu'elle est donc un
permis moins cher
28 millions d'euros l'an dernier contre
11 millions auparavant donc c'est quand
même une petite butte assez incroyable
il ya des subventions publiques aussi
qui sont passés de 27 mille euros en
2017 à ces trois millions en 2021
attention en compensation de
responsabilité était autrefois la charge
du préfet et qui incombe aujourd'hui aux
chasseurs s'est pas non plus des
subventions comme ça pour n'importe quoi
et puis une cerise sur le gâteau qu'est
dénoncée par les associations anti
chasse et une éco contribution de 10
euros par paire me conquérir qui
reversait pour financer des projets de
reconquête de la biodiversité est là
pour le coup les associations disent que
c'est des projets sont pas assez précis
on voit pas assez certaines disent que
ce route on demandait aux cowboys
marlboro de de financer les campagnes
anti tabac comme pour coiffer tant de
gestes d'affection pourquoi tant de
gestes d'affection de la part du
président la république on pourrait dire
que sa terre natale la picardie est une
terre de chasseurs peut-être le poids de
l'histoire dans sa lettre aux chasseurs
emmanuel macron salué un attachement
séculaire à la ruralité ses traditions à
son environnement à ses paysages au fond
la chasse lui donne des racines une
certaine partie de la population lui
dénient par ailleurs et puis il pense
aussi que c'est un facteur
d'attractivité il l'avait dit par
exemple les chasses présidentielles
encore remise mais ça ça fait partie de
l'attractivité de la france et a peu de
tout ça sans doute mais aussi surtout le
gibier électorale qui l'intéressent on
parle d'un million de licenciés et en
rajoutant les familles et les amis qui
vont avec peut-être quatre millions de
personnes sur les estimations les plus
basses et ça ça vaut bien quelques
quelques cartouches dorées il ne restait
que quelques minutes dans dans ce débat
merci mathieu je voudrais qu'on parle de
cette cette idée d'un jour sans chasse
tancrède delà de la morinerie est ce que
c'est c'est quelque chose dont vous
voulez absolument pas entendre parler ou
alors peut y avoir une discussion
comment vous positionner par rapport à
ça
déjà moi je représente pas les chasseurs
fut pas je suis journaliste la
fédération nationale des chasseurs mais
ce que je sais c'est que en fait le jour
chantage ça existe déjà dans plein de
département il faut savoir déjà que les
forêts donc les forêts qui sont gérés
par l'office national des forêts il n'y
a pas de chasse le week-end par exemple
c'est ce que en semaine il ya plein de
départements moi je suis par exemple
normande ans dans la manche il ya deux
jours par semaine où on chasse pas donc
ce que veut dire de ce que je comprends
les aménagements d'eau par le sénat
c'est en fait en termes d'homogénéité ce
n'est qu'il ya déjà plein département il
ya plein de secteurs y amène comme le
commune par commune et où on peut pas
chasser donc je comprends bien pour des
gens qui sont contre la chasse qu'il ya
un marqueur l'espèce de journée sans
chasse mais c'est à dire qu'il y aurait
une journée son vtt il y aurait une
journée je sais pas sans s'en voir se
promener à cheval une journée sans
pouvoir ramasser les champignons j'aime
bien mais en terme de jeu c'est que moi
je trouve ça un peu contraignant et y
après il ya autre chose c'est que là on
parle puisque c'est un peu le sujet du
jour des phases de grand gibier il ya
des chasses par exemple a pas l'ombre
dans le sud ouest on chasse le migrateur
le migrateur il choisit pas les joueurs
voyez pour migrer donc imaginé une
immigration à jour qu'il soit vendredi
la chasse faire pour être
dans les palombières mais en tout cas
sachez que dans quasiment tous les
départements il ya déjà des journées où
des lieux où on change pas sas et c'est
partout partout en france ben oui
justement le problème c'est que c'est un
millefeuille administratif on s'y perd
demain je vais en vacances dans le gers
je veux aller me balader avec mes
enfants dans la forêt je vais devoir
aller chercher sur internet cg droit
d'aller ce jour là dans cette forêt là
sur ce sentier là on est complètement
perdu plus de 60% des accidents de
chasse en lieu le dimanche dans le
rapport il est clairement proposé donc à
plusieurs reprises par exemple
proposition 19 de favoriser la prise
d'un arrêté interdisant l'accès aux
zones de chasse lorsque les conditions
de sécurité le justifie donc le rapport
propose d'interdire aux non chasseurs
l'accès à des forêts et nous ce qu'on on
est là pour la sécurité on n'est pas là
pour le grand gibier ou quoi on est là
parce que les chasseurs représentent un
million de citoyens français contre 67 à
peu près millions de citoyens non
chasseurs et on
on a notre liberté de circulation notre
liberté de jouir à un droit à un
environnement sain qui est complètement
altérée pour l'activité de loisir et
éventuellement de régulation de certains
chasseurs donc c'est ça non on demandait
juste à ce qu'il y ait une journée
nationale pour qu' on n'est pas avant 2
si on veut sortir spontanément se
balader en forêt on n'est pas à chercher
aussi on peut si on peut pas qu'est ce
qu'il en est et il ya des mères qui
pousse encore plus loin dans la nièvre
il ya un maire qui a pris un arrêté
récemment et qui oblige les non
chasseurs qui vont se balader à porter
des gilets jaunes et si vous ne portait
pas de gilet jaune vous avez une
contravention de 135 euros donc on est
complètement dans une version 1 millions
de personnes détiennent le pouvoir sur
la nature à l'instant là et pourtant il
couvrira les i allez-y vous donne ma
parole ah non mais alors le gers ont
pris je connais bien il s'avère que
madame vous parliez d'année vous
promener en forêt juste rappeler quelque
chose c'est que ça c'est un droit j
support rien mais en tant que tout
citoyen vous pouvez pas aller vous
promener partout vous voyez il ya la
forêt privée en france
la loi fait que si vous avez envie de
vous promener il ya déjà deux fait des
endroits qui vous sont interdits ou sans
l'accord du proviseur donc ça déjà
quelle que soit la temporalité vous
pouvez pas y aller donc là on parle des
forêts publiques des forêts communales
et celle là c'est extrêmement simple le
week-end vous pouvez parfaitement aller
vous promener dans ces fois là puisque
il faudrait gérer par le hénaff ya pas
de chasse comme pics allant même de
façon plus générale on parle des
accidents on a clos la saison de chasse
l'année passée avec une en donneuse de
25 ans qui s'est fait huer par une
mineure de 17 ans parce qu en france à
15 ans on peut chasser et même à partir
de
partir de 15 ans peut pratiquer la
chasse accompagnée sans avoir passé un
examen sans mentionner on pas juste une
journée ou une demi-journée de formation
et on peut aller chasser à 15 ans on
peut tirer sans avoir permis de chasse
donc la saison de chasse s'est clôturée
par une ordonnance de 25 ans tuée ça a
ouvert ce week end qu'est-ce qui a eu à
une deux noms chasseuse qui se sont pris
des plombs sur sur leurs parties du
corps et un chien tué et dans et un
automobiliste qui s'est pris des plombs
et le chien et la rando d'ascq et se
sont pris des plans étaient chez eux
donc là on parle en dehors de ça on
parle même pas de randonnée en bande de
jours on peut être chez soi tranquille
alors bon sens entendre on va terminer
ce débat est perdant 2 1 termine avec
deux éléments d'abord la réaction ça y
est même tombé officielle en cette fin
d'après midi de la fédération nationale
de la chasse qui parle d'un rapport
choquant qui va coûter très cher aux
chasseurs qui vont - chassé et donc ça
va pénaliser les territoires ruraux en
fait il met l'accent sur le la
faisabilité de la mise en oeuvre de ces
mesures qui seraient trop coûteuse pour
les chasseurs évidemment c'est un début
d'un débat ça peut aller vers une
proposition de loi et va y avoir encore
des amendements vers des discussions
bref on en est qu'au début février vous
allez avoir le mot de la fin
en fait c'est un peu de la ddt j'ai un
peu l'impression qu'on parle d'un côté
d'une france éternelle
peut-être un peu rêver et et de l'autre
voilà d'une france qui est en train de
bouger qui est ça craque un peu quoi oui
on aime bien les caricatures en france
et le manichéisme via la france qui
avance la france des villes et puis à la
france oui la france pauvre l'apprend la
france se figer sur ses valeurs
éternelles dont voilà le coup de chasse
fait par le petit fils avec son grand
père le dimanche matin c'est un peu
désuet c'est en train de disparaître
faut jamais oublier qu'à l'échelle
locale ya une excellente entente en
général entre les chasseurs et les
autres gardiens de la biodiversité bien
plus nombreux que sont les associations
de protection de la nature ou les cpu
etc etc qui travaillent souvent très
bien notamment sur les zones humides y
aurait peu de zones humides notamment en
baie de somme qui serait encore
existantes en france des zones humides
côtières cents l'action conjuguée des
naturalistes et des chasseurs ce que ce
dont convient d'ailleurs assez
régulièrement la lp au
sens les chasseurs et les naturalistes
qui aurait pas ce qu'on appelle les
trams écologique et trame verte et bleue
parce que les chasseurs avec les
naturalisme en particulier les chasseurs
qui sont tout le temps dehors celles qui
connaissent le moindre bosquet le
moindre chemin creux et sans eux la
cartographie des zones à protéger serait
difficile à faire il n'en reste pas
moins qu'il ferait mieux de faire
quelques concessions notamment sur ce
jour de chasse et puis arrêtez cette
excuse moi du terme cette saloperie
qu'aient le la chasse aux blaireaux
entre autres chasses dégueulasse parce
que s'ils ne le font pas ils vont perdre
le peu qui leur reste de soutien dans la
population urbaine et ça pourrait
précipiter leur faim demain on pourrait
très bien avoir un pays sans chasse et
on y perdrait quelque chose dans notre
culture dans notre anthropologie ce
serait quand même dommage
je vous en prie même si à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat valérie que
j'appelle le titre de votre livre c'est
la chasse le ferai le vrai du faux c'est
publié aux éditions delachaux et niestlé
et puis tiens je voudrais vous
conseiller un roman premier roman le
titre c'est bichi des signes et mona
messine jeu en train de le lire c'est un
hasard absolue c'est un jour de chasse
vu par la biche qui raconte vous laisse
imaginer c'est très très bien écrit
merci encore à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat ici en plateau et en duplex est
désolé pour ce voile à ces difficultés
ça arrive rarement c'était pour ce soir
mais on s'en est sorti et je suis sûr
que ce débat vous a passionné
[Musique]